life is full of conflict it's full of
conflict you know and uh sometimes you
say things sometimes sometimes you say
things they think about doing a lot of
podcasts brennan
i have my ten thousand hours
i shoot doors
i shoot from the head when we're having
fun we're talking
we talk and sometimes we shoot from the
hip and then you might say something
about family members which you've done
about my family your family which i've
done i've got we've got some trouble my
dad stopped listening to the show oh
i've gotten loud we lost a subscriber
i've had to make major apologies too dad
you don't listen to show you this no i
quit listening years ago and we okay
because it hurts their feelings oh yeah
i've had to make apologies to my own
family
but many times yeah because he and i'll
just get going which is trying to make
each other conversation it's comedy you
forget people listen and you also forget
sometimes that you're you're you grew up
in locker rooms so locker room humor
is for everybody it's not for everybody
if you're your team's rough you your
rough teaser i'm a big great dane you're
a big great forget healthy games
and since i've known brendan i've always
said brendan you can't walk into a room
looking the way you do being able to
kill everybody in the room with your
bare hands and also be
mean
or
t is rough because what happens is
people go that guy they mistaken
they mistake your sensitive dude i know
you very well you're very sensitive very
generous guy much more generous than
people know i love you too generous i
love you i love you
you're not you you make money but you
don't think about money you spend money
like on people you do a lot of great
things
but you're not sometimes the most
sensitive because you're on your way
somewhere if i feel backed in a corner
or if there's something else you're very
sensitive he's actually super sensitive
okay he'll actually depending on things
you can get him to cry you can make him
cry if you tease him he'll get a lump in
his throat and it's my joke i go guys a
lot of guys they don't we don't let
we don't let the sad get to our eyes
what we do is we go i'm sad and i'm
going to turn this [ __ ] down
i'm sad somebody needs to [ __ ] die
that's what we do or or i roast
well that's what you do so you go
ah i'm feeling sensitive
my feelings a little hurt
and i'm gonna fight you punch sometimes
you you're a fighter
not physically not punch as far as punch
is like you you you'll say something and
then you go then you have time to think
about it and you feel a little bad
now you're referring to harold hawani i
might be referring to ariel
i know i think it's i i just thought it
was important to bring it up because
now you know i text them apologize
yeah i believe that yeah i believe that
no i'll show you the thing
we were at the gym
yes yeah we were at the gym with you
guys i went i [ __ ] up yeah and then i
saw you on monday i made a mistake and
you know
with the whole aerial stuff it's like
it's like a drone strike
you're aiming for a target there's gonna
be some casualties ariel isn't my focus
we're not in the same lane ariel and i'm
gonna say this because i i've i don't
know ariel well but i've done i think we
did a podcast or something with him
ariel's very sensitive
tonight yeah he's very sensitive we're
at fox ariel i've always said ariel's a
very good journalist he's the best we
have he has very very important
questions but ariel's [ __ ] very
sensitive i don't know much about him
well he's a very sensitive because
he's he's a guy who he's worked hard for
what he has no there is a very good
journalist i said it on the fight
companion
but but but he's sensitive some people
are and he's also and i'm sensitive but
i'm not going to say anything ariel will
voice his
he'll literally
express it okay he's a journalist and he
says he shoots from the hip too and he
speaks his mind now you did say from the
hip no but you did say what did you say
exactly that he objected to
uh
did you make a joke uh
did i make a joke i think you made a
choice i said he's like a weatherman
because like journalists to me are
whether like if they're like a
weatherman yeah i remember clocking that
and i went ooh we were doing the podcast
because usually i would have had you and
you know i'm not like that no but you
you like i said he was a casualty of the
big my i have no issue with her him
working at showtime has nothing to do
with me i we don't even do the same job
yeah i know so him being there has
nothing whether i was there or not he
would have still been there so i made it
seem like the only reason he was there
is because i turned down that's not
that's not the way it went down he's
great at what he does i'm good at what i
do
we're in two separate lanes yeah so my
my issue was not with him but it came
out he was a byproduct of it sounded
like
yes i remember clocking that and i i
would have i would have reminded you
that i don't want you to put that in
there because i knew you didn't mean
that but it was live and so he probably
it probably got back to him
but did something else get back to him
did you say something about when you
come to l.a
well i said that on below the belt and
showtime's going to edit all the time
i said yeah no don't say it okay
it's locker room humor okay ariel's too
sensitive yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
and yeah but also he shouldn't be he
shouldn't be in my uh scope anyways yeah
he's a byproduct of all this so and i
apologize for it i text him apologize
for it he wrote me this novel there's
obviously some underlying other issues
that he has issues with
with you you mean or yeah in general you
know if you're a sense of guy that's
what it is so it sounds like you just
want to have dialogue
maybe you know
i i you know i i don't know that's not
what i do yeah yeah entertainment so so
he he was he was upset about the fact
that you brought up the brock lesnar
thing
no i didn't bring it up now years ago
because i had heard that in 2015 ufc 199
the narrative is and i'm not a reporter
i don't this is just the narrative this
is the narrative of the entire world and
this is what you've said on the fight
companion is i didn't say this on the
fight campaign
but i think that's where his
uh kind of
attitude towards me comes is uh ufc 199
he leaked the brock lesnar news and got
his credentials pulled and banned from
the ufc that was dana right because
danica was dana that was the ufc but and
then you know in his text he goes and he
goes do you really think they'd ban me
over something a little like that
i do because you gotta remember at ufc
199 what was ufc trying to do with ufc
200 announced brock lesnar sell the
company yeah they're trying to get
evaluated for the maximum you know
whatever four billion dollars and then
having brock lesnar was gonna do that so
by him stealing their shine releasing it
it's a business that's why dana was like
you're out of here now let me just stop
you you said no i don't report that
right now now you just said him stealing
the sign and reporting that ariel may
have a different point a story on that
and that may not be fair to him but
that's what i heard too all i'm saying
is that but the entire
community heard that yeah but that but
again and all you were doing was
reiterating that you were just saying
that yeah you didn't come up with that
story that's just something you think i
mean i heard that i heard that story did
i hear from the horse's mouth which is
dana no but i heard it from the they say
the wrangler yeah
you know what i'm saying the guy who's
the closest to the horse well we all
knew he was also a close friend yeah or
i don't know eerie yes i don't know
ariel wasn't allowed we're not friends
we haven't allowed wasn't he banned from
yes yeah so we all knew that now do i
think they should abandon them no right
that's not my doing i'm not a journalist
right i don't dig into the story i don't
give a [ __ ] that's not what i do yeah
that's his issue so that word was kind
of already around it was it's been
around forever i didn't start so you
didn't start anything no god i know i
don't have that i don't have i i guess i
could tell you it wasn't like you were
saying something new i think that
happened
i think what happened was on the fight
companion
brandon was talking we were having a
great time drinking water we're drinking
whiskey but we were just talking and
ariel came up i i was joking around
because i've seen
i've seen how how it's my fault because
rampage jackson i remember wouldn't talk
to arrow one time and i always thought
he had a beef and i just i was just
joking i remember rampage said he cost
me two million dollars yeah and i said
you don't like you don't like ariel
joking around he goes i have no problem
with ariel i was just trying to i was
just i don't know i just brought it up
you're not familiar i wasn't trying to
stir [ __ ] no you're not in this world
you don't know the background i wasn't
trying to be mean i was just and then he
he i said yeah he said something about
some two million dollars yeah something
a lot of money and so um but again i
don't think ariel did that no he didn't
do it on purpose but we were just
talking and i think ariel felt
mischaracterized fair point and he got
upset
because that's the narrative around him
right like difficult to work with well
what
i've never worked with the guy but he
seems like he was he's working a lot oh
yeah he i mean look he's a very good
journalist he's the best we have and
he's an important journalist yeah we
need him you need guys yeah yeah yeah
you need him because ariel will ask the
tough questions once again and and
i think he's a very sensitive guy he's
not a knock he's just sensitive i think
he went on some podcasts from what i
heard and kind of my boy pat mcqueen
maybe mischaracterized you a little bit
i didn't see him but
yeah you know maybe not maybe not but i
think but i thought for sure he did but
my thing like even that's fine
i'm not that sensitive even that doesn't
bother me should i slap you just for
ariel should i give you a little slap
just to make it can i treat you like i
would ariel
do you want to put on a suit and glasses
and i'll slap you around a little bit oh
hold on
why no i thought no because
because i feel like i should be allowed
to slap you because you
but he doesn't get slapped no because
you drew first blood and i think they
were a little bit and i think you were a
little bit insensitive but was he in the
way how was it first blood if he wasn't
saying anything new
well i did call him a weatherman
oh okay
i was gonna do it
oh that's a heavy bro then yeah that's
for you right that was a heavy sweat
ariel
yeah why you gotta hit him now i feel
like he needs to be a little more
careful with how he characterizes people
she would have to hit the mail something
hard
i didn't hit him that hard no i didn't
hit him hard enough for him to get it
was i i heard like give me ct like that
horse
yeah but i heard
with that slap yeah my my thing is the
world's negative enough and that's why i
text area i went dude our jobs are tough
enough we don't need to start a war
doing that [ __ ] man you focus on what
you do i focus on what i do that's it
dude